come on work you piece of crap what's a
tinder can i really trust this alexa
lady internet explorer is why do I need
an icon Oh how to answer your family's
tech questions
[Music]
this damn wireless router is so slow
I've been drinking grandma's eggnog
since 8:00 this morning okay grandpa
it's probably because your router was
old that's why I got you this a new neck
gear or B that helps cover the whole
house in Wi-Fi the other problem is who
had it in the back office any router
should be located in the center of the
house and yes if the connection drops
unplug it and plug it back in now I can
get to my AOL Mail faster what about the
printer it's possessed by an evil spirit
like your cousin Georgie actually the
printer was just out of cyan ink so use
new paper keep extra ink handy and when
wireless printing isn't working restart
the printer or reconnect to the wireless
network or just plug in directly yay I
have one password for my Gmail one for
my Amazon one for my iTunes is there a
better way than this yes I'm so happy
you asked Aunt Jane a password manager
is way better than this I got you one
called dashlane it's an app for your
computer and phone that securely stores
all your passwords so you don't forget
them you just need to remember the
password to dashlane to get in but
that's a lot there are no buts when
dealing with our security Aunt Jane cuz
of Sam's Facebook and email was hacked
what can I do to keep safe
I'm gonna show you how to setup
two-factor authentication that means
companies asked for another form of
authentication or proof that it's you so
when you log into your email or Facebook
on a new computer it will require a
special code that's sent to your
smartphone I keep getting this pop-up to
update my iPhone software can you make
it go away there I made it go away by
installing it they are important not
only do they contain new features but
they
contained security updates I keep
getting this note from Apple that I'm
low on storage and I don't have any
iCloud space what's iCloud space all
right now let's take a look here in your
iCloud settings looks like your iCloud
space is being taken up by photos of
random cats that means we need to buy
more space you and Dad can share it with
family sharing 200 gigabytes cost $3 a
month
oh just pay for it ma all right you guys
all good this one's for in stuff what's
that
[Music]